[Music]
one thing we have to be very clear on is
that leadership is not personality some
leaders do have charisma but a lot of
the very best leaders that we studied in
the course of history had what I might
call a charisma bypass and they are not
people who would jump across a table at
you some of them can be almost strange
in their behaviors some of them can be
magnetic in their behavior some of them
can be harsh and abrasive in their
behaviors and when you when you look at
all that you say well wait a minute
leadership is not personality and in
fact if you're highly charismatic that's
not necessarily a positive because the
critical thing we found about how people
engage with a leader is not about this
external stuff that's really pretty
irrelevant it has to do with the answer
to a simple question why are you in it
are you fundamentally doing something
that's about you or are you trying to
build something great to accomplish
something great to build great products
or whether to be a build a great company
or to change a bunch of kids lives in a
school or to accomplish a mission in
Afghanistan I mean if it's fundamentally
about you as a leader why should anybody
give themselves over to what you're
trying to do but if it's fundamentally
that you're channeling your ego into a
cause or a company or a set of work or
something that you're trying to
accomplish that is not about you that's
when people sign up
you